delegates could we please ask you to
take your seats thank you
you don't have my number
now
[Music]
pulling me down
the people of the city
i don't need your counsel now
[Music]
we don't need each other
conference please welcome baroness
doreen lawrence
[Applause]
uh
thank you
[Applause]
hello
my name is dorian lawrence
i think you all know my story
like so many of you i've spent my life
fighting for people to get justice they
deserve
campaign against racism
helping to ensure that young people can
fulfill their potential
trying to build a better country
about 15 years ago i met kia stammer
he was a lawyer then
he was known for being on the side of
ordinary people
even back then he had good hair
here's always always on the side of
families who deserve justice
he took the decision to prosecute my
son's stephen's murder murderers
it meant that finally some justice was
done
he has been a friend to me ever since
through my campaigning i've met a lot of
people i've met a lot of people who talk
a lot
but here is someone who listens and acts
that's why when i said
i could be his race advisor he said yes
because i knew it wouldn't just be about
talking
it would about changing things
he asked me to investigate the impact of
covid on on on minority communities
i was shocked by what we found
how
black communities were badly affected by
covid
because of the inequality in our society
how people's health was so badly
impacted by the discrimination they
faced
how inequality made the pandemic so much
worse
hidden kia didn't just read my my report
he said
this must lead to lead to real change
and when i'm prime minister
it will do
that's the sort of man he is
and that's the sort of prime minister he
will be
someone who doesn't just believe in
justice equality security and
opportunity
but someone who just worked his work his
whole life to help people
to get them
i'm proud to call here my friend
and i'm proud to work with him as leader
of the labour party
and i'm proud to introduce him to you
now
[Applause]
[Music]
our next labor prime minister and leader
of the labour party
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much conference
i've waited
i've waited 17 months
25 days and two hours
to appear in front of you in this hall
as leader of our great party
and dorian
thank you for your kind words
thank you for everything you've done for
criminal justice thank you for
everything you've done for our party
i'm so proud to call you my friend thank
you dorian
[Applause]
and conference let me take this first
opportunity to thank my brilliant shadow
cabinet and shadow lords team for
everything that they have done in the
last 18 months thank you so much colleen
[Applause]
and louise allman
welcome home
[Applause]
this hasn't always
this hasn't always been an easy
conference
sunday was particularly nerve-wracking
but then the results
started coming through
arsenal three
tottenham one
[Applause]
conference before i start let me tackle
the issue of the day
head on
if you go outside and walk along the
seafront
it won't be long be talk before you get
to a petrol station that's got no fuel
level up
you can't even fill up
and
[Applause]
and conference doesn't that just tell
you everything you need to know about
this government
ignoring the problem
blaming someone else
then coming up with a half-baked
solution
why do we suddenly have a shortage of
hgv drivers
why is there no plan in place
a tank of fuel already cost 10 pounds
more than it did at the start of the
year
gas and electricity bills up
gaps in the supermarket shelves
rent up especially for those on the
lowest incomes
yet this
is the very moment
the government is putting up tax on
working people
putting up tax on small business
and shamefully slashing
universal credit the lifeline for six
million families
[Applause]
we have a fuel crisis
a pay crisis a goods crisis and a cost
of living crisis all at the same time
conference let me quote to you what the
prime minister said at the united
nations last week
we believe that someone else will clear
up the mess we make
because that's what someone else has
always done
well
prime minister
either get a grip or get out of the way
and let us step up and clear up this
mess
[Applause]
this is our first full conference
since the 2019 general election
in which we suffered our worst defeat
since 1935.
to our devoted activists to our loyal
voters
i want to say loud and clear
you saved this party from obliteration
and we will never forget it thank you
[Applause]
but my job as leader
is not just to say thank you
to the voters that stayed with us
it is to understand and to persuade the
voters
who rejected us
to those labour voters
who said their grandparents would turn
in their graves
but they couldn't trust us with high
office
to those who reluctantly chose the
tories
because they didn't believe that our
promises were credible
to the voters
to the voters that thought we were
unpatriotic
or irresponsible
or that we look down on them
i say these simple
but powerful words
we will never under my leadership go
into an election with a manifesto that
is not a serious plan for government
thank you
[Applause]
it will not take another election defeat
for the labour party to become an
alternative government in which you can
trust
[Applause]
and conference
that's why it's been so important to get
our own house in order this week and we
have done that
[Applause]
this this is a
at this time on a wednesday it's
normally the tourists that heckling me
doesn't bother me then
don't bother me now
[Applause]
this is a big moment in our country's
history
we will look back at this moment
and we'll ask
how did the nation rebuild after the
pandemic
did we learn
did we use the crisis to make the future
i see a government lost in the woods
with two paths beckoning
one path leads back
where we came from
none of the lessons of covid are learned
the flaws that were brutally exposed by
the pandemic all worsen
childhood poverty increases
the crisis in social care
gets worse the housing market still
broken
slow
and steady
decline
but there's another path
down which we do address the chronic
problems revealed by covid
with the kindness
and the togetherness
that got us through
that path
leads to a future in which a smart
government
enlists the brilliance of scientific
invention
to create a prosperous economy
and a contribution society in which
everyone
has their role to play
it will be a future in women in which we
make an opportunity
out of tackling the climate crisis
and in which britain is once again a
confident actor
in the world
i believe in this country
and i believe we will go forward
today
i want to tell you how
today i want to tell you where my
passions were born
and why i'm in politics
there are two rocks in my life
the two sources of what i believe
to be right
and good
family
and work
i'm not from a privileged background
my dad was a tool maker
although in a way
so was boris johnson's
[Applause]
my dad
was a tool maker
in a factory that worked on the shop
floor all his life
he gave me a deep respect
for the dignity of work
there are some lines from ordon that
capture the beauty of skilled work
you need not see what someone is doing
to know if it's his vocation
you only
have to watch his eyes
how beautiful it is
that i on the object look
i saw that eye on the object look in my
dad
the pride that good work brings
it puts food on the table
and it provides a sense of dignity
so
so when i hear that this country is
creating so many low-paid jobs
and when i tell you that good work and
fair growth will be the priority for a
labor government
i haven't learned this in some political
seminar
i learnt it
around the kitchen table
at home
from my dad
how pride derives from work
how work is the bedrock
of a good economy
and how a good economy
is an essential partner of a good
society
that is why i am so proud to lead a
party whose name is labor
don't
[Applause]
don't forget it
don't forget it labor the party of
working people
[Applause]
my mum worked incredibly hard too
she was a nurse in the nhs
and a very proud nurse too
i got from my mum
an ethic of service
but my mum was also unfortunately
a long-term patient of the nhs
when she was young
she was diagnosed with stills disease
it's a rare form of inflammatory
arthritis which severely restricts
mobility
this d disease
along with the drugs she had to take to
control it
took a very heavy toll
the nhs
that had been her livelihood
became her lifeline
there were times
many times
when mom was so ill
that she had to go into hospital
i remember going into the intensive care
unit one day
as i often did
mom's bed was a riot of tubes and
temperature devices
i could sense the urgency in the
conversations of the four nurses
on my mum's bed
i knew
without being told
they were keeping her alive
i can hardly convey to you the emotion
of seeing your mum
in that condition
and there was a sort of horrible irony
in the moment
i just picked up an award
for work i'd done on the death penalty
which in my own way
was about trying to save people's lives
i've gone to the hospital
hoping to tell my mom about it
and there
in front of me
those four nurses
were working to save her life
when that long day was over
i thanked them for what they'd done
and they said to me
we're just doing our job
and they were
they were doing their job for my mum
that night
somebody else's mom the night before
somebody else's mom the night after
but that's not just a job
it's a calling
so when i think
so when i think of the extraordinary
dedication of doctors and nurses working
to keep people alive as the covet virus
took hold
i know what that looks like
i understand what that means
so just as we stood on our doorsteps and
applauded let this conference ring out
its approval to the nhs staff truly
the very best of us
[Applause]
so
so you see
shouting slogans or changing lives
conference
[Applause]
thank you conference
so
so you see
family life
family life taught me
taught me about the dignity of work and
the nobility of care
conference
as i say slogans or changing
lives slogans we can chant all day
we can chant all day
[Applause]
the conference
conference
even with a name like here
i was never one of those people reared
for politics
i became the first person in my family
to go to university
the first
the first to go into the law and every
day as a lawyer
if you're a young radical as i was you
think of yourself as working for justice
you see people getting a raw deal and
you want to help
justice
for me
was not a complicated idea
justice
to me
was a practical achievement
it was about
seeing a wrong
and putting it right
that's my approach in politics too
down to earth
working out what's wrong
fixing it
[Applause]
i had the great honor of becoming this
country's chief prosecutor
leading an organization the crown
prosecution service
three very important words
crown
brings home the responsibility
of leading part of the national legal
system
prosecution tells you
that crime hurts and victims need
justice to be done
[Applause]
service is a reminder that the job is
bigger than your own career advancement
[Applause]
i will always remember the day
that john and penny clough contacted my
office
their daughter jane was a nurse
who'd been the victim
of terrible domestic abuse
after repeated assaults
jane summoned the very great courage
to report her partner
he was arrested
and remanded in custody
but then
very much against the wishes of the
cloth family
he was let out
on bail
jane lived in constant fear
that he would return
to harm her
she tried to ensure
she never traveled to work
alone
the one morning
that jane arrived at work
unaccompanied
he was waiting for her
in the hospital car park
where he stabbed her
71 times
when jane's parents
got in touch
my office advised me
not to see them
you can't get emotionally involved in
cases they said
i replied if i haven't got time to see
the parents of a young woman who's just
been murdered
then what am i doing in this job
[Applause]
on the day that john and penny were
supposed to come and see me
to tell me about the cruel murder of
their daughter
and how the criminal justice system had
let them down
my own daughter
was born
we had to push back the meeting it was
an incredibly emotional day for all of
us
as i listened to john and penny tell me
jane's story i knew that a great
injustice had been done i made a promise
to john and penny at the end of that
first meeting
that i would work with them to make sure
that no other family went through what
they'd been forced to
endure and we rolled up our sleeves
and we changed the law
i am delighted to say
that john and penny have become good
friends of mine
and i am beyond honored
that they have joined us here today
conference
john
and penny clark
[Applause]
please
john and penny taught me
how to keep your dignity
under severe pressure
doreen lawrence
taught me the same lesson
hers was a long battle
for justice for stephen against the odds
confronting racism but never giving up
[Applause]
her courage and resilience over 28 years
is impossible to describe in words
i honestly don't know
how i would cope
if anything happened
to one of our children
i do know
that i am humbled
by john
by penny
and by dory
[Applause]
and that is why under my leadership the
fight against crime will always be a
labor issue
a labor issue
[Applause]
labor will strengthen legal protection
for the victims of crime we will not
walk around the problem we'll fix it
conference when i learned
that 98
of reported rape cases don't end in a
criminal charge
i couldn't believe it
i asked my team to check the figures
that can't be right i said
but it was
shocking
so we will fast track rape and serious
sexual assault cases and we will toughen
sentences for rapists stalkers and
domestic abusers
[Applause]
this is part of who we are
because it's part
of what i am
today
today conference i'm here to tell you
what i stand for
but i'll also tell you what i won't
stand for
i won't stand for two million incidents
of anti-social behavior this year
i won't stand for record levels of knife
crime that we have in this country today
and i won't stand
for nine out of ten crimes going
unsolved
[Applause]
under the tories the criminal justice
system is close to collapse
there's never been a bigger backlog in
the crown courts
after 11 years of tory government we
have lost more than 8 000 police
officers
they pretend it doesn't make any
difference
it does
ask the workers on the day shift at tata
steel in wolverhampton
they told me about the repeated
incidents in their neighborhood
all the young women i recently saw in
stoke who told me that they dare not go
out in their high street alone
they see
more violence
and fewer police
it's just common sense to put the two
together
the tories are letting you down and i
can promise you that will never happen
under my leadership
[Applause]
thank you
conference was something else i took
from a career in the law
and that's that there's one law
and it applies to everyone
now i try to remain calm in the bare pit
of parliamentary politics
i'm not a career politician
i came to politics late in life
and i don't much like point scoring
[Applause]
but the one thing
about boris johnson
that offends everything that i stand for
is his assumption that the rules don't
apply to him
[Applause]
when dominic cummings took a trip to
barnard castle to test his eyesight
boris johnson turned a blind eye
when matt hancock
breached his own lockdown rules
boris johnson declared the mata closed
when i got pinged i isolated
when boris johnson got pinged he tried
to ignore it
that's not how i do business
[Applause]
when i was the chief prosecutor and mps
fell short of the highest standards on
their expenses
i prosecuted those who had broken the
law
[Applause]
politics has to be clean
wrongdoing has to be punished
conference there are times in this
parliament when i feel like i've got my
own job back
contracts handed out to friends and
donors
the former prime minister
lobbying the chancellor by text
refurbishing number 10 with a loan from
an anonymous donor
on behalf of the public
that cares about clearing up politics
i put this government on notice
[Applause]
i've spent my entire working life trying
to get justice done
in 2003 when i was working with the
policing board of northern ireland
when i was learning up close just how
hard it is to make a split-second life
and death decision in a riot situation
as i work with the police to create a
lasting institution in accordance with
the good friday agreement
boris johnson was a guest on top gear
where in reference to himself
he said to jeremy clarkson
you can't rule out the possibility that
beneath the elaborately constructed
veneer of a blithering idiot
lurks
a blithering idiot
[Applause]
when in the autumn of 2010 i was the
chief prosecutor working with doreen
lawrence
to finally get a prosecution of the two
men that murdered stephen
boris johnson was writing an article in
the telegraph declaring a war
on traffic cones
and when this country was threatened by
terrorists who were trying to bring down
planes with liquid bombs
i spent the summer of 2010 helping to
put those terrorists behind bars
where they could no longer pose a danger
to british citizens
[Applause]
and whilst i was doing that
what were you doing mr johnson
you were writing a piece
defending your right
not to wear a cycle helmet
conference it's easy to comfort yourself
that your opponents are bad people
i don't think boris johnson is a bad man
i think he's a trivial man
i think he's a showman
[Applause]
he's a showman with nothing left to show
he's a trickster who's performed his one
trick
once he's said the words
get brexit done
his plan
run out
there is
no plan
the questions we face in britain today
are big ones
how we emerge from the biggest pandemic
in a century
how we make our living in a competitive
world
the climate crisis
our relationship with europe
the future of our union
these are big issues
but our politics is so small
these times demand a responsible leader
with clear values
from my dad
from my dad i understand the dignity of
work
from my mum
i appreciate the nobility of care
from my work the principle that we are
all equal before the law
and from the victims
of crime
that the law is there
to make us secure
work
care
equality
security
[Applause]
that's what i mean by justice
and that's what i've been aiming at all
my working life
that's why i'm in politics
and those are the values this country
needs
as we first seek to recover from the
pandemic
and then to look with excitement
anticipation at the path that beckons us
to retal britain for the future to make
this nation anew
[Applause]
i want to start with the importance of
care
covert 19 exposed the state of britain
after a decade of cuts neglect
the health service wasn't ready
just when the nation
needed four nurses on its bed
sadly
they couldn't always be there
1.6 million older people were going
without the care they needed
gp numbers had tumbled
waiting list for treatment had spiraled
then
on top of that
the government was fatally slow to
respond
the prime minister's inability to make
up his mind really mattered
britain has the worst death toll in
europe
we have lost
000 people to covert
every one of them
somebody's mom
dad
sister
brother
friend
i know it was difficult
but the situation is worse than it
needed to be
and it wasn't just a government failure
over 18 months
it was a failure of the government's
duty of care over 11 years
11 year old
[Applause]
there are cracks in british society and
coveted seeped into them low earners
were at greater risk
so were black and ethnic minority
communities
coveted forensically found those who
already had health problems
and it's left in its wake a significant
backlog
nhs waiting lists are at the highest
level on record
five and a half million people are
waiting for treatment
the great scandal of the pandemic
was what happened in our care homes
and let me tell you this conference
an unfair tax hike that doesn't fix
social care and doesn't clear the nhs
backlog is not a plan
[Applause]
we know that people will still be forced
to sell their homes for care
working people will have to pay more
but there's still no plan
a plan would prevent problems before
they bite
a plan would provide care at home
where people are
a plan would ensure the workforce was
properly valued
and a serious plan wouldn't be funded by
hammering working people
[Applause]
there is no doubt that the nhs needs
more money
and a labor government will always fund
the nhs properly
but the future of the nhs can't just be
about chasing extra demand with more
money
and neither can it be about reshuffling
the furniture in yet another pointless
reorganization
we have to
we have to understand
the big moment
that the nhs faces
in 1900
the average british person expected to
live to the age of 48.
today
average life expectancy is 80.
the number of people aged 65 and over in
this country is growing three times
faster than the number aged under 65.
that is a wonderful achievement
and the biggest test
in the history of the nhs
no society in british history has been
as old as our modern nations
small politics
will no longer do
i want britain
to be the healthiest nation on earth
so let me tell you what labour would do
we would shift the priority of the nhs
away from emergency care towards
prevention
[Applause]
we can catch problems early and at the
same time we can use the resources of
the nhs better
and i don't just mean physical illness
either
with every pound spent on your behalf
we would expect the treasury to weigh
not just its effect on national income
but also its effect on well-being
[Applause]
let me give you an
example one of the urgent needs of our
time
is mental health
labor will guarantee that support will
be available in less than a month
[Applause]
we will recruit the mental health staff
that we need over 8
500 more mental health professionals
supporting a million more people
every year
[Applause]
under labour spending on mental health
will never be allowed to fall
and we'll make sure that children and
young people get help early
by ensuring that
every school
every school has specialist support and
every community has an open access
mental health hub
[Applause]
conference this is prevention in action
helping young people looking after their
well-being
it's the principle
my mum taught me
the principle
of care
let me give you a flavor of what care
will look like in the future
i was at university college hospital in
london recently
an orthopedic surgeon told me about a
robot
this robot sits on the operating theatre
making sure every incision is just right
the sergeant can't go wrong because the
robot works an override system
a bit like driving a car with a driving
instructor
the doctor and the robot working
together are so efficient
that patients can be discharged a whole
day early
over time
that means thousands of hospital beds
are freed up
the range of possibility is bewildering
precision editing of the genome will
help us wipe out pathogens
the science of robotics and exoskeletons
will help patients
who are struggling to move
virtual reality is being used to
alleviate suffering of post-surgical
pain
i could talk about this all day i
promise i won't
i don't pretend to understand all the
medical science
but as politicians
we have to recognize the scale of what's
happening
and put the power of smart government
behind it
[Applause]
that is what care will mean in the
future
this is how health
will be remade
and then we need to give our young
people the tools of the future
education is so important
i'm tempted to say it three times
[Applause]
when you don't invest in young people
the whole nation suffers
and the less fortunate get behind
by the time they finish their gcses
pupils from poorer families
are 18 months behind their wealthier
peers
that's right
18 months
the pandemic showed that you can't trust
the tories with the education of our
children
children on free school meals
going hungry
there was u-turn after u-turn on school
closures
the attainment gap between rich and paul
grew
the government asked kevin collins a
recognised expert in the field to be
their recoveries are
he told them what they needed to do
and they said
no
when he saw the government plans which
he described as feeble
mr collins had no option
but to resign
if you can't level up our children you
are not serious about leveling up at all
[Applause]
and even before the pandemic
200 000 children
grew up in areas
with not a single primary school rated
as good
or outstanding
just think about that
not a single primary school rated as
good or outstanding
i want every parent in the country to be
able to send their child to a great
state school
[Applause]
on top of that if you can believe it 40
percent of young people leave compulsory
education without essential
qualifications what's that say about
their future
we will not put up with that
that is why labour will launch the most
ambitious school improvement plan in a
generation not walking around the
problem but fixing it
[Applause]
under labour education will recover
but education needs to do more than just
recover
it needs to be pointed in the direction
i took from my dad
towards skill
towards work
employers in all sectors tell me that
they need well-rounded young people
young people skilled in life
ready for work
young people who can communicate and
work in a team
that's why it's stupid to allow theater
drama and music to collapse in state
schools
[Applause]
we want every child to get the chance to
play competitive sports and play an
instrument
[Applause]
when i was at school
i had music lessons with fat boy slim
i can't promise that for everyone
not even here in brighton
but i can promise
that labor
as the name tells you
will make a priority of getting this
country ready for work
that's why we will focus
on practical life skills
we will reinstate two weeks of
compulsory work experience and we will
guarantee
[Applause]
and we guarantee that every young person
gets to see a careers advisor
[Applause]
but conference conference
young people won't be ready for work
all ready for life
unless they are literate in the
technology of the day
fewer than half of british employers
believe young people have the right
digital skills we do much worse in
computer skills than most of our
economic rivals
that is why labour will write a
curriculum for tomorrow
[Applause]
reading writing and arithmetic are the
three pillars
of any education
we would add a fourth
sadly doesn't begin with our
digital skills
we need
we
need to ensure that every child emerged
from school ready for work
and ready for life
and confidence
as in health so too in education
we can work by the light of new
technology
machine learning can cater for
individual work styles
artificial intelligence can help tuition
especially for students with special
needs
cloud computing has brought the archive
of the best that's been said and done
to the handset of every student
there is so much possibility
and all we have to do
is to learn to adapt
i think my dad might appreciate the
technical term that's used for this
change
it's known in the trade
as retooling
and conference what is the small tory
idea to respond to this change
they want to reintroduce latin
in state schools
so let me put this crisis
in the only language that boris johnson
will understand
carpe diem seize the day
seize the day
[Applause]
finally it's time to act to educate our
young citizens in the skills they need
for work and the skills they need for
life
a society that cares
an education system that fosters the
skills
that's the foundation
of an economy
that works
in his great study the wealth and
poverty of nations
david landis explains why britain was
home to the first industrial revolution
the perfect home for growth said landis
had responsive honest government i'll
say no more about that just at the
moment
it tended to favor
the new over the old
enterprise over conservatism it spread
the rewards evenly to make sure most of
the talents were recognized all of the
time
but the most important factor of all
the lesson we need to relearn
was that britain led the world
in the technology of the day
the flying shuttle the spinning jenny
the power of the loom these inventions
were once the wave of the future
in textiles iron energy and power
britain was a pioneer
i know
that with labor
we could do that again
but every day we waste
with a government with no industrial
strategy
we're falling further behind
a scientific revolution is happening
around us
but if we don't have a government ready
to remake the nation
the opportunity
will pass us already too many people are
shut out of economic reward
we once took it for granted
that our children would enjoy
more than their parents
that idea
drove my mum and dad
it comforted them that whatever the ups
and downs of life
they were living in
and contributing
to a better society
but after 10 years of the tories
we've lost this
we have 5.7 million people in low paid
and insecure work
workers in transport
care
education and the utilities
these were the people
who kept the show on the road during the
pandemic
and their reward
is continued low pay
and job insecurity
the millennial
the millennial generation
clustered in low-paid jobs will be the
first generation to have lower lifetime
earnings than the one that went before
after a decade of the conservatives
we have an economy with historically low
rates of investment
since 2010
in the investment league
of 170 nations
britain comes in
a miserable 150th
labor will work with sectors
which are strong
pharmaceuticals
materials
defense chemical engineering consumer
goods environmental technology transport
and biotechnology
under labour's
buy make and sell in britain program
there will be more local procurement
the towns that were the crucibles of the
original industrial revolution
need to be revived in the next
the coal and cotton towns of lancashire
the wool towns of yorkshire
the great maritime and fishing economies
of our seaport these places
made britain the envy of the world
we cannot make the nation we want
without them
the lesson is that a secure well-paid
workforce of skilled people in
high-class work
protected by good trade unions is not
separate from good business
it is the definition of good business
[Applause]
and good business and good government
are partners
i have no doubt that the small
businesses of this country are the next
generation wealth creators
i want to see enterprising creative
companies
i want to see them make a profit and
employ more people
i want to create the conditions in which
inventive small businesses can grow into
inventive big businesses
but we don't give ourselves the best
chance
i've lost count of how many business
leaders have told me
that they wish their time horizon could
be longer
so when i say that labor pledges to
change the priority duty of directors
to make the long-term success of the
company the main priority
we will do it with the blessing of
british business
[Applause]
a focus on the long term will allow for
better investment
labor will make britain a world leader
in science and research and development
and we will set a target to invest a
minimum of three percent of gdp
this
this nation will not grow
with the low wages low standard low
productivity of the tories i'm
determined we're going to change this by
investing in our businesses by
unleashing our creativity by bringing
forward the new deal for working people
launched by anger on saturday
[Applause]
this is how we remake our nation
the good society
and the strong economy
as partners
without a good society we waste the
talents of too many people
without a strong economy we cannot pay
for the good society
talk is cheap
but progress isn't
if we want permission
to create the good society
we have to win trust that we will create
a strong economy
[Applause]
the economic inheritance from the
tourists will be appalling
a botched brexit
followed by covid has left a big hole
the government is learning
that it's not enough
to get brexit done
you need a plan to make brexit work
i i do see a way forward after brexit if
we invest in our people and our places
if we deploy our technology cleverly
and if we build the affordable homes we
so desperately need
but the public finances we inherit
will need serious repair work
i take the responsibility of spending
your money very seriously
that's why our approach to taxation will
be governed by the three principles
the greater part of the burden should
not fall on working people
[Applause]
the balance between smaller and larger
businesses
should be fair
and we will chase down every penny to
ensure that people
working people paying their taxes
always get
value for money
as rachel said on monday
all spending will be scrutinized by an
office for value for money
there will be no promises we can't keep
or commitments we can't pay for
too often in the history of this party
our dream of the good
society falls foul of the belief
that we will not run a strong economy
but you don't get one
without the other
and under my leadership we are committed
to both
and i can promise you now
under my leadership labor will be back
in business
let me give you an example of
how this template can work
let's take
let's take the hardest question on the
biggest issue of our time
climate change
this is an issue of security
it's a test of justice on a global scale
climate change poses an existential
threat
it will turn fertile terrain into desert
land
conflicts will break out over scarce
resources like water
millions will be displaced by flooding
forest fires and violent storms
time is short
and we have a duty to act
but but that obligation shouldn't daunt
us
it should embolden us
shifting the economy onto a sustainable
path is full of promise for britain
full of promise
every time i enter a high-tech factory i
wonder what my dad would have made of it
not so long ago
we shaped metal
by drilling it
milling it
and turning it
i remember my dad working with a spark
eroder
submerging metal in a liquid
and using an electrical charge to shape
it
we thought it was revolutionary at the
time
but at airbus recently
where they're developing the world's
next hydrogen wing
i saw them working with 3d engineering
literally shaping components by bringing
together particles of matter in a way
completely unimaginable in the factory
my dad used to work in
i saw young apprentices in a fully
unionized factory
proud of the skilled work that they were
doing
and their pride
came from knowing
that they were at the heart
of a revolution
building the next generation of hydrogen
and battery planes
they felt like pioneers of flight
perched on the edge of a cliff
taking the risk
knowing that success for one of them
would change the world
in scotland
i saw the great potential of wind power
at whiteley wind farm
yet conference of the 250 wind turbines
at whiteley
not one of them not one of them
was made in britain
from their manufacturing base in fife
the workforce can see the turbines
literally
being towed in
from places like indonesia
the next generation of deep sea wind
turbines could be our opportunity
skilled engineering offshore work
sectors
where we could lead the world
if only
we had a government
willing
to lead
public funding was an important
component of so many inventions
the personal computer
the internet
the iphone
if only we funded science seriously we
could make a historic contribution to
the battle against climate change
action is needed
not in the future
but now
if we delay action by a decade the cost
of climate transition will double
this
urgency
is why labour will bring forward a green
new deal
[Applause]
thank you
our green new deal
will include a climate investment pledge
to put us back on track to cut the
substantial majority of emissions this
decade
and if we're serious about climate
change
we need to upgrade our homes
the tories inherited plans from labour
to make every new home zero carbon
they scrapped them
they scrapped them and now we have a
crisis in energy prices
emissions from homes have increased
and we have the least energy efficient
housing in europe
so it will be labour's national mission
over the next decade to fit out every
home that needs it
to make sure that it is warm well
insulated and cost less to heat and will
create thousands of jobs in the process
[Applause]
i can also pledge that we will introduce
a clean air act
and everything we do in government will
have to meet a net zero test to ensure
that prosperity we enjoy does not come
at the cost of our climate
[Applause]
and that's why on monday rachel set out
her ambition to become britain's first
green chancellor
committing the next labor government to
an additional 28 billions of capital
investment in our country's green
transition for each and every year of
this decade
[Applause]
like those pioneers in flight
unlike those young engineers working on
the next generation plane
we have it within our grasp to make a
historic difference
we have it within our grasp
to be the change we need
in the world
after a decade of tory government how we
need that change
under the tories wages have fallen in
every english region
local government has been cut to the
bone
more than half a million more children
live in poverty
and so do half a million more pensioners
for the first time
in decades
life expectancy
has stalled
and after all that
the tories expect us to believe
that leveling up is more than a slogan
well
let me offer the conservative party a
lesson in leveling up
if they want to know how to do it
i suggest they take a look at our record
the last time we were in government
[Applause]
so
hospital weights down
gcso results up
44 000 more doctors
89 000 new nurses
child poverty down 1 million
pensioner property down 1 million
rough sleepers down 75 percent
a national minimum wage
conference
[Applause]
the oecd said that no nation that had a
bigger rise in social mobility than
britain you weren't leveling up
that's leveling up
[Applause]
and you can see the benefit of labor in
power today
look at what our fantastic metro mayors
mayors and local authority leaders are
doing
and let's hear it
for the difference mark drakeford and
his team are making in wales
[Applause]
i have a great relationship with mark
but i fear that it's under threat
i believe
in the union
of the nations on these
[Applause]
islands but we have a cavalier
government that's placing it in peril
scotland
is in the unfortunate position of having
two bad governments
[Applause]
the tour is in westminster and the smp
in hollywood
when nicola sturgeon took office
she said she wanted to be judged
on her record
well these days with the poorest in
society less well-educated
and less healthy
and with the tragedy of so many
drug-related deaths
we hear rather less about the smp's
record
the snp and the tories walk in lockstep
they both exploit the constitutional
divide
for their own ends
labour is the party that wants to bring
our nations together
[Applause]
under the fantastic leadership of
anasawa labour is the party of the union
because it's not just
that divorce would be a costly
disruption
although that's true
and it's not just that
our union is in all our economic
interests
though that is also true
it's that we're more progressive
together we are more secure together
we're a more bigger presence in the
world together
[Applause]
we are greater as britain
than we would be apart
[Applause]
as gordon brown said recently
when a welsh or scottish woman gives
blood
she doesn't demand an assurance that it
must not go to an english patient
i'm delighted that gordon will lead our
commission to settle the future of the
union
[Applause]
and i know that gordon believes that if
you look past the tourist pathetic
attempts to divide us in a culture war
you can glimpse a tolerant progressive
nation of which we can all be proud
[Applause]
i believe that our diversity is one of
the things that makes this country great
as this
country
as this country continues to change
as we slowly liberate the talents of
more people
as we name and tackle discrimination
as we make a better place for people
with disabilities i believe we grow as a
country
when the government ignored marcus
rashford's campaign on school meals
i was shocked
but i couldn't believe it
when rashford and the england team took
the knee
to highlight and condemn the racism that
they had had to endure
the home secretary encouraged people
to boo
well
in this conference hall we are patriots
[Applause]
when we discuss the fine young men and
women who represent all our nations we
don't boo we get to our feet and we
cheer
[Applause]
let me say a word too
about another band of great british men
and women
our military
put themselves in harm's way to protect
our security
i am proud of them
[Applause]
and i'm proud of the work they did for
us in afghanistan
thank you
[Applause]
it grieves me
to see britain isolated and
irrelevant labor is the party of nato
the party of international alliances
[Applause]
under labour we will rebuild our
alliances we will mend broken
relationships and we will do right by
the great britains who serve in our
armed forces
[Applause]
i can see
i can see the ways in which we can
remake this nation
and that's what we get to do
when we win
[Applause]
in a way the more we expose the
inadequacy of this government the more
it presses the question back on us
if they're so bad
what does it say about us
because after all
in 2019
we lost to them
and we lost badly
i know that hurts each and every one of
you
so let's get totally serious about this
we can win the next general election
this
this government can't keep the fuel
flowing it can't keep the shelves
stacked
and you've seen what boris johnson does
when he wants more money he goes
straight to the wallets of working
people
labor is the party that's on the side of
working people
so imagine
just imagine waking up
the morning after the next election
in the knowledge
that you could start to write the next
chapter in our nation's history bending
it towards the values that bring us year
after year to this conference hall to
seek a better way
proud in the knowledge
that you were part of it
[Applause]
i have loved my first full conference as
leader i've really loved it
but i don't want to go through the same
routine every year
in a few short years from now
i want to be here with you
talking about the difference we're
making the problems we're fixing as a
labor government
[Applause]
that is what this party is for
that is the object of the exercise
and as the leader of this party
i will always have
that eye on the object look
how beautiful it is
that i on the object look
this is a big moment
a time of rapid change
the first pandemic in a century
the aftermath of brexit to sort out the
urgent claim of the climate
than our own domestic questions
providing a secure job that pays a
decent wage
a good school nearby
health and social care that you can rely
on
a home you can afford
this is a big moment
that demands leadership
leadership founded on the principles
that have informed my life
and with which
i honor
where i have come from
[Applause]
work
care
equality
security
i think of these as british values
i think of them as the values that take
you right to the heart of the british
public and that is where this party must
always be
[Applause]
i think of these values as my heirloom
the word loom from which the idea comes
is another word for tool
work
care
equality
security
these are the tools of my trade and with
them
i will go to work thank you conference
thank you congress thank you
thank you thank you thank
you thank you
oh
[Applause]
ah
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
conference please welcome sisters
shamely and divya mia who were leaders
in the singing of the red flag in
jerusalem
[Applause]
the people's flag is deep is red
it shrouded off our mother dead
and e their limbs grew stiff and cold
their hearts blood died it's
every fold
then raise the skirt
[Music]
snake
swear we
[Music]
scream
we
[Music]
[Applause]
you